bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver à
la u2 ça vous regarde ce soir l'écologie
au secours du quinquennat d' emmanuel
macron depuis la mer de classe au pied
du mont blanc
le chef de l'état a amorcé un virage
écolo un tournant vert
mais pourquoi faire les annonces sur la
biodiversité notamment sont elles à la
hauteur de l'urgence le réveil
écologique du président posture ou
imposture on en parle dans un instant
dans notre grand débat on se fout de
nous certains départements ne décolère
pas sur les conditions du retour aux 90
km conditions bien trop drastiques à
leurs yeux alors que la mortalité a
atteint sur les routes son plus bas
historique et d'un l'autorisation du
gouvernement de repasser à la vitesse
maximale serait tel un troupeau l'oeil
on en parlera et puis notre grand témoin
ce soir est une figure de l'écologie
ancienne ministre de l'environnement
elle se bat aujourd'hui dans les
tribunaux pour les victimes des
catastrophes naturelles et industrielles
corinne lepage est avec nous ce soir
voilà vous savez tout hashtag sévère
n'oubliez pas c'est parti on y va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir corinne
lepage bonsoir soirée merci d'être notre
grand témoin on a beaucoup de questions
et de sujets à vous soumettre ce soir je
rappelle que vous êtes avocate bien sûr
président du rassemblement citoyen cap21
et parmi ces sujets liés à la sécurité
routière on va en parler tout à l'heure
le retour à 90 km/heure ya le rapport
parlementaire sur lubrizol puisque vous
connaissez parfaitement sujet je
rappelle que vous défendez un certain
nombre de victimes de cette catastrophe
industrielle mais on va commencer avec
la carte postale du jour emmanuel macron
au pied du mont blanc dans la mer de
glace pour toucher du doigt les effets
dévastateurs du changement climatique et
amorcer je le disais un virage écolo un
virage écolo dans la vallée de chamonix
on va en parler avec vous bruno milian
bonsoir vous êtes député modem des
yvelines
hervé kempf bonsoir rédacteur en chef de
reporter un site d'actualités sur
l'écologie vous publiez l'écologie du
21e siècle
il s'agit d'une série d'entretiens avec
différentes figures de l'écologie on
peut citer claire nouvian ou pablo
serving enfin bon soir julien blanchet
bonsoir merci d'être là vous êtes le
rapporteur général de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat c'est 150
citoyens tirés au sort qui vont plancher
sur et qui planchent en ce moment au ceo
conseil environnemental et social sur
l'agenda vert pour 2020 quelles
responsabilités on en parlera je vous
donne la parole dans un instant celui
qui nous emmène dans les cimes de haute
savoie c'est stéphane blakowski dans son
billet quotidien
comme tous les soirs si j'ai bien
compris tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir peut pas mon sens meriane
bonsoir messieurs bonsoir stéphane si
j'ai bien compris ce soir peur si j'ai
bien compris mais vous avez déjà révélé
l'événement emmanuel macron s'est
converti à l'écologie
bon alors même temps y'a rien de très
étonnant ça puisque tout le monde s'est
converti à l'écologie
regardez nous mêmes ici est ce qu'on
sait pas convertir et l'écologie fini
les gobelets en plastique
on n'a des vers en vrai verbal est vrai
ces derniers devaient rentrer il m'a pas
parce qu'on n'est pas les seuls et les
insoumis eux sont pour l'écologie
solidaires même marine le pen et pour
l'écologie a dit le protectionnisme
moins de commerce international - de
production de sonner tout le monde est
écolo donc un maquereau en cette
conversion collective c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour la planète
bah dis d'abord quelle bonne nouvelle
puisque tout le monde est d'accord sur
l'idée qu' il est urgent d'agir pour
sauver la planète
donc forcément on va y arriver mais
quand on est d'azopé denise un peu comme
ça naïf un peu béat
ça me rappelle cette chanson des
compagnons de la chanson est alors comme
il a pas mal de seniors qui nous regarde
pas je pense que ça va
[Rires]
[Musique]
la main le voilà ça paraît un peu naïf
comme ça mais c'est à dire une cause qui
mériteraient qu'on se donne tous la main
c'est l'écologie n'en est encore rien
dit rien et tout le monde le dira sur ce
plateau l'individualisme gangrène notre
société il est urgent de trouver une
cause commune un truc qui nous
réunissent l'écologie bien sûr mais à
défaut de se tendre la main parce qu'on
a du mal au moins se serrer les coudes
c'est ce que disait yannick jadot ir je
crois à chez bourdin plus de 80 % des
français pensent que si on se serre les
coudes on va surmonter les grands défis
et vous savez quel est le sujet sur
lequel les français pensent qu'on va me
donner un récit commun qu'on va enfin
avoir un projet partagé pour nous et
pour nos enfants
eh bien c'est la protection de
l'environnement la protection de
l'environnement mais alors là tu mets
quelques incidences pas ça c'est
quasiment incroyable exactement ce qu'a
dit macron aujourd'hui mais il a dit la
même chose il a dit il faut un combat
qui resserre les rangs de la société et
ce combat
bah ce combat il en parle c'est
l'écologie ce sera le combat lui sied
celui de notre capacité à inventer mais
nouvelle manière de vivre d'habiter de
fer d'uranium
je crois que ce combat du siècle nous
pouvons le relever et nous avons décidé
de relever dans notre pays on en vous
croyez vraiment qu emmanuel macron et
yannick jadot vont se donner la main
pour trouver la vraie bombe
non j'y crois
moyennement c'est sûr mais quand bien
même ça arriverait je veux dire s'il se
mettait d'accord et que tous les
français arrêtaient de rouler en voiture
on représente 1% de la production de co2
dans le monde donc c'est même pas notre
décision qui réglerait l'avenir de la
planète mais quant à l'idée que l'idée
d'environnement la protection de leur
nom puisse servir de cause commune où
ils puissent nous servir à faire un peu
plus société même là j'ai un doute
puisque macron fait des propositions
mais d'équité une proposition les
écologistes les vrais ceux comptant
poule où ils source est nulle
voilà vous dire est maintenant bel avait
un peu caricatural et 10 passes nuls 6
et 10 nuls on écoute
julien bouilhou je viens prépare dont je
vous avais troubles et julien bayou et
vous répéterez décennies la presse
est-ce que tout est nul dans le bilan
écologique des manuels maintenant je
vous dis en matière de biodiversité il
aggrave la situation en permettant de
chasser c'est ce qu'a soutenu le oui
bien sûr cela rien c'est que des mots
ouais c'est assez lapidaire en tout cas
comme réponse comme le mot est bien
choisi lapidaire une parole qui
correspond à péage été inséré que macron
dit un truc sur l'écologie ont dû pas
déjà mais peu de sincérité et tout de
suite on lui jette la pierre donc
elisabeth bornes qu'est ce qu'elle fait
elle se défendre elle rappelle que les
écolos bon bah ils ont aussi un passif
je rappelle que europe écologie les
verts il était au gouvernement au début
du quinquennat précédent
est-ce qu'ils ont fermé les centrales à
charbon est ce qu'ils ont arrêté notre
dame des landes
est-ce qu'ils ont arrêté le projet
europa city est ce qu'ils ont est-ce
qu'ils ont accompagné les français pour
supprimer un million de chaudières fioul
comme on est en train de le faire est-ce
qu'ils ont permis de sortir de la sig de
la circulation un million de voitures
polluantes donc moi je n'ai pas de leçon
à recevoir
enfin pour terminer stephan se tournant
vers des manuels macron vous y croyez
vous écoutez tout le monde jusqu'à
présent voulait régler prennent du
chômage personne n'avait réussi à battre
on est en train de régler le problème du
chômage
pourquoi ils ne réussiraient pas sur
l'écologie bon maintenant il faut se
méfier des grands discours
moi je vous ai dit qu'on était devenu
écolo avec le
vers qu'on mettait devant les caméras
est en fait en coulisse on compte
utiliser une fontaine et des verres en
plastique j'espère que maintenant pas
comme nous mais j'espère que ce n'est
pas que de la com et qu' il est un peu
plus sincère que nous parce que nous on
triche mais nous nous dans l'équipe de
ça vous regarde on va faire beaucoup
mieux c'est en cours alors beaucoup de
choses dans ce dans ce billet corinne
lepage pour commencer se tournant vers
vous y voyez vous ai dit que c'était nul
non mais si vous voulez il ya des choses
intéressantes à dire que tout et tout et
acheter c'est pas vrai mais si vous
voulez moi je suis dans le pratique aux
pratiques je vois ce qui se passe depuis
deux ans et demi et j'assiste depuis
deux ans et demi à la déconstruction
systématique gelé dire à une échelle
industrielle du droit de l'environnement
on a supprimé cet avocat dans ses
pensées mon métier j'ai un doctorat de
droit aussi au passage donc c'est un peu
mon métier aussi les normes
environnementales les études d'impact
réduites à leur plus simple expression
suppression au moins partielle des
enquêtes publiques réduction massive du
recours aux études de danger ça donne
lubrizol par exemple et comme ça ne
suffit pas en même temps que le
président de la république et à chamonix
projet de loi devant le parlement de
entre guillemets simplification où on va
encore réduire les études d'impact les
enquêtes publiques
permettre aux industriels de bénéficier
de droits acquis que jusqu'à maintenant
il n'avait pas le pouvoir commencer des
travaux quand on a pas encore
l'autorisation etc etc
pour moi la vraie vie c'est ça la vraie
vie c'est d'aider projets partout dans
la france il est à la montagne très bien
dans le même temps la france vient
d'autoriser les suisses sont fous de
rage une autoroute à thonon la 412 qui
va servir à rien du tout et qui va
ramener encore un peu plus de flux dans
la maison que vous iriez quoi il ya un
double 10 mai quad et enfin d'hypocrisie
c'est un double discours c'est à dire
qu'il ya des actes qui eux sont très
contraire à l'environnement et de très
belles paroles de très beaux engagements
sens du respect à un centime qu'ils
soient mis dessus parce que ça c'est
très bien de parler des choses mais
quand on met pas les moyens en face ça
sert strictement à rien je pense me suis
moi on va aller vers un vous de me dire
les mesures dans le détail
on va vous les monts valin on peut pas
dire qu'il n'a rien dit il a dit des
choses mais ce que je vous dis c'est que
dans la vraie vie c'est le contraire qui
est fait renault 1000 yens qu'est ce que
vous répondez parce que c'est vrai que
en général quand ya une campagne
électorale
on l'a vu avec les européennes tout d'un
coup le sujet de l'écologie revient en
force et c'est le cas là avec le
tournant vert on se dit qu'il ya une
forcément une arrière-pensée peut-être
électorale non mais loin loin de ces
schémas la campagne électorale égale
programme écologique etc
c'est la marche en avant pour l'écologie
l'environnement et la protection
l'environnement elle est obligatoire
il n'y a pas un politique aujourd'hui
alors de bonne foi de mauvais soit peu
importe qui ne peut pas s'engager vers
l'environnement alors à des à des
vitesses ou avec des moyens différents à
huis clos à l'elysée le président de la
république et il vous a convaincu de
faire de l'écologie la priorité de ces
prix là le texte qui va sortir
effectivement d'ici à la fin du
quinquennat
sur quoi sur l'écologie on en a pas les
détails mais ya effectivement été exclu
en préparation là dessus moi je voudrais
rappeler parce que pour reprendre à
corinne lepage sont ce côté un petit peu
quand j'avais deux corées oui elle
pointe des choses qui moi me gêne je
peux pas dire le contraire je serai de
maloney dans la broye l'environnement
notamment
oui oui on l'a vu on l'a vu il ya des
choses qui nous ont alertés mais à côté
de ça il ya quand même énormément de
choses qui sont faites concrètement
aussi sur le territoire moi je pense
notamment à ces contrats de transition
écologique
il y en a 80 qui ont été signés depuis
deux ans c'est un milliard can ou contre
ces des appels à projets qui ont été
lancés par le ministère de
l'environnement et et que on fait avec
les collectivités parce que le problème
de l'écologie et de l'environnement
c'est qu'il faut qu'on a traduit sur le
territoire font qu'on entraîne avec nous
les collectivités et c'est pas forcément
ce qu'il ya de plus simple pour
entraîner je vous le dis premier contrat
signé il ya deux ans par sébastien
lecornu
deux ans après on en a 80 1 milliard 500
millions d'euros d'investis ça va de la
ferme solaire assez importante d'un gros
coup alentours de 300 millions à des
plus petites choses de type de
méthaniseur agricoles etc
donc les collectivités s'engagent c'est
sur le terrain qu'on va gagner seul
intérêt dans les territoires de la même
façon il ya eu aussi les contrats de
transition énergétique
qui nous a permis ce que disent les
abattements n'avait pas tout à fait tort
mais ce qui nous a permis notamment de
fermer les derniers thermique non je
suis un très léger dernière son train de
chenilles novation thermique par exemple
pourquoi on irait à rénovation thermique
des logements dick sait même pas quand
même pas qu ils le parti au niveau local
je passais koala moi j'ai posé note je
peux le dire franchement j'ai posé une
auto nissan la transition écologique et
solidaire en disant voilà on se trompe
depuis des années sur la rénovation
thermique en faisant ce fameux séité là
pour la rénovation ça ne profite qu'aux
gens qui ont les moyens parce que vous
pouvez faire tout ce que vous voulez
même s'il ne voit ce que 10% à charge
pour rénover votre logement les
bailleurs pauvres peuvent pas le faire
c'est très bien aller sur le fond vous
avez raison terminé pardon elle a aussi
pareil on passe par les collectivités
territoriales qui mieux que les
collectivités territoriales connaissent
leur immobilier si voilà lors leur
situation immobilière
et puis on va aller faire bâtiment par
bâtiment les plus dégradés d'abord si
les gens les moyens de payer un peu ils
paieront un peu s'ils ont pas les moyens
de payer tout ce qu on a foutu en l'air
depuis des années avec tous ses étés eux
eh bien on le fait c'est l'ensemble des
boissons qui s'est mis en mouvement mais
on va revenir aux images avec elle parce
qu'il a choisi la mer de glace
il a choisi le mont blanc pour au fond
revenir au diagnostic ça peut être
étonnant parce que les français le
connaissent le diagnostic c'est un peu
comme s'il s'adressait à ceux qui
doutaient encore des ravages du du
climat enfin du dérèglement climatique
on va écouter à nouveau emmanuel macron
purement je réagirais juste après tout
ces dérèglements je le disais sont ici
tangible je pense que c'est une
pédagogie collectif extrêmement
important de la montrer à nos
concitoyens
si d'aucuns devait encore douter si
certains pouvaient penser que cela peut
attendre
voilà les français ne pense pas que ça
peut attendre c'est vrai que ce choix de
communication l'a peut être étonnant non
oui le le degré avec lequel nos cieux
mâcon se fiche du monde effectivement
absolument stupéfiant on a fait un 10/10
tôt ce matin en disant macron le bouffon
de l'écologie terme ou son dictionnaire
un bon français un comédien qui joue la
farce qui joue la pantomine on sait
depuis maintenant des années des
dizaines d'années même j'allais dire
depuis jacques chirac
la maison brûle nous regardons ailleurs
en 2002 que vient faire monsieur mâcon
ci faisait ce beau discours très bien
mais s'il y avait des actes derrière une
fois de plus or le problème c'est que
non seulement la politique
d'environnement n'avance pas même s'il
ya des points positifs on va pas dire
que tout est absolument négatif et vous
avez rappelé l'engagement de l'examen
sur la jante en des contrats de
transition écologique mais je confirme
absolument ce qu'a dit corinne lepage
on a fait une grande enquête d'un
reporter sur le détricotage du droit de
l'environnement
c'est complexe compliqué mais c'est très
important l'office français la
biodiversité devant lequel monsieur
macron a voulu parler en finance
aujourd'hui hier les moyens sont
diminués par rapport aux différents
organismes qui la verrait que cahill
avait réuni l'eau nf l'office national
des forêts qui est un enjeu essentiel en
matière de biodiversité forestière est
en fait en voie de privatisation avec
des impératifs de productivité
l'artificialisation des sols continue
avec très souvent l'accord des préfets
et du gouvernement comme à port la
nouvelle
comme pour l'autoroute toulouse cadeaux
comme toujours la double discours c'est
un double discours c'est une
bouffonnerie au bout d'un moment ça
devient ainsi un portage julien blanchet
c'est intéressant parce que aller sur la
mer de glace et et constater les dégâts
d'une certaine façon des français le
savent il ya déjà des sondages qui sont
extrêmement préoccupants les français
sont pessimistes 65% des français
pensent que la civilisation va
s'effondrer dans les années à venir
instinct sondage de l'ifop pour la
fondation jean jaurès aujourd'hui
et bah s'effondrer faute enfin la
civilisation telle que nous la
connaissons actuellement va s'effondrer
dans les années à venir c'est un sondage
très sérieux 65% c'est énorme
et quand on leur pose la question de
savoir si les français s'ils lui
l'exécutif va dans le bon sens en
matière d'écologie sont deux tiers a
considéré que le gouvernement ne fait
pas assez pour lutter contre contre le
réchauffement climatique
vous qui travaillez la convention
citoyenne ces chiffres là les citoyens
qui travaillent en ont conscience
oui oui alors ce sondage cfo faut aussi
parce que c'est un comparatif
internationale donc c'est aussi
intéressant de voir ce que disent et
l'italie il va encore plus est ce que et
quelles sont les réactions aussi des
français et parmi ces réactions là
effectivement il pense qu'une des
solutions ou après cet effondrement
puisque c'est un peu ça le sujet il
estime qu'il y aura une démocratie plus
participative et bien je crois que cette
convention citoyenne finalement répond
en partie à sa effectivement mais déjà
le fait qu'un tiers des personnes avec
qui nous avons une conversation au
téléphone quand le tirage a été au sort
a été réalisé sous contrôle d'huissier
avec un certain nombre de critères pour
s'assurer de la diversité de ses 150 et
bien un tiers disent et spontanément
oui et je crois que c'est à la fois
l'exercice démocratique et l'enjeu
climatique qui fait qu'il ya cette envie
de trouver des solutions parce que sur
le constat globalement tout le monde est
d'accord sur les solutions monsieur
raison depuis les années 70 ce joie
qu'il y avait jean jouzel qui fait
partie du comité de gouvernance de la
convention citoyenne qui était aussi à
chamonix
jean jouzel il le dit depuis un moment
qu'il ya un problème qui a urgence et
qu'il faut réagir que c'est trop tard de
consensus dans la société sur les
solutions est donc cette convention
citoyenne et bien et vise à permettre de
créer de consensus sur les solutions
parce qu'être d'accord sur le constat
effectué aujourd'hui ça ne suffit plus
donc trouver des solutions communes
associées le citoyen à la décision ou
même le faire créer certains fûts de
chêne mais cette solution tout en tout
temps ce qu'elles soient acceptables ces
solutions d'affaires un référendum afin
de faire durer le plaisir est ce qu on
sent qu'il ya aussi des doutes au sein
de de cette convention citoyenne sur les
résultats finaux sur la capacité bien
sûr à ce que tout soit repris sans
filtre et d'expression alors tout soit
repris sans filtre qu'on comprenne bien
il s'agit pas de déposséder les
parlementaires de leur droit
d'amendement mais ce qui est promis là
dessus on est là et on était mal on
était mal je voulais pas quitter plateau
précipitamment donc oui ça aurait été
gens non mais blague à part c'est quand
même un sujet c'est un sujet pourquoi
parce que effectivement je crois que cet
exercice qui s'inscrit dans le paysage
institutionnel et c'est pas pour rien
que ça se déroule au conseil économique
social et environnemental
effectivement demande à trouver des
articulations avec les autres formes de
représentation mais effectivement le
référendum est une possibilité ouverte
où la voie parlementaire en est une en
ce projet de loi dont on vous a parlé le
président mardi soir ce sera sera
sûrement le résultat du résultat des
travaux et moi je voudrais il ya un
moment je voudrais qu'on arrête de
forcément tout critiquer dans ce pays
parce que cette convention citoyenne
c'est quand même le prélude à la
démocratie participative que les
citoyens réclament nous derrière ça nous
engage c'est à dire que si on les des
soins eh ben c'est fini donc moi je les
connais le nom mais les solutions les
connaît tous c'est pas le problème c'est
l'acceptation des solutions par les
citoyens qui est compliqué et c'est pour
ça que je vous parlais des contrats par
exemple la taxe carbone voilà une bonne
idée et ce n'était pas très bien n'être
voilà ça a été très bien acceptée c'est
pour ça que je vous parlais des contrats
de transition écologique ou des contrats
de transition énergétique parce que ça
ça se fait sur le terrain avec les gens
et les gens il faut qu'on lui n'arrive à
les convaincre ça se fait pas comme ça
on n'arrive pas simplement disant on va
faire ça les gens disent oui
faut les convaincre c'est terrible et
corinne lepage beaucoup plus que moi je
pense puisque elle a été aux affaires
avant moi c'est comment c'est difficile
de faire accepter des solutions dont on
pense à juste titre qu'il faut les
prendre tout de suite et maintenant mais
que les gens n'acceptent pas la
convention citoyenne qui va fixer
l'agenda de mézin c'est quand même
normal non salut la traçabilité de
démocratie participative à la condition
de sa vie jusqu'au bout et à la
condition que ça se termine pas en eau
de boudin
c'était cette proposition là non
franchement ça va pas faire plaisir at
on était là économique au septuor
l'exercice je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
j'ai été très inquiète quand j'ai
entendu le président de la république
dire que s'il y avait un référendum y
seraient consultatifs
c'est pas le sujet savez vous qui a du
reste vous savez qu'on peut pas passer
on peut pas faire un référendum à
questions multiples par exemple sans
qu'ils ne soient que consultatif mais je
crois qu'effectivement faudra enlever
les vois pas là donc je pense que c'est
un très bon exercice
ce que j'espère c'est que sera pas
et que c'est vraiment l'expression de
ceux qui auront dit quelque chose qui
ressortira sur la manière dont certaines
conférences de consensus ont abouti à ce
que ce soit quelqu'un d'autre qui rédige
le papier et que ce qu'avaient dit les
gens finalement passe totalement à la
trappe amène à être prudents parfois ça
peut très bien se terminer un jeune
reste je ne sais pas bien qu'ils
participent sont pas du genre docile ans
le rendre je suis un pied deux petites
choses que je voulais dire moi je suis
de l'avis de monsieur le député c'est
sur les territoires que les choses se
passent mais je crois pas qu'ils aient
des problèmes d'acceptabilité il ya une
très forte demande des collectivités
locales des citoyens des entreprises de
faire des choses localement
sauf que dans un certain nombre de
domaines et en particulier en matière de
décentralisation énergétique très
franchement il faut avoir l'âme
chevillée au corps pour mener à bien un
projet aujourd'hui en france l'état
contrôle encore trop à l'onda il n'avait
pas du tout envie qu'on développe en
france les énergies renouvelables genre
désolé de casser
ranger nos pages quand même c'est quand
même en train de changer parce qu'on est
en train notamment de simplifier vous le
savez notamment pour on avait beaucoup
les aliens wiggo les éoliennes mais
aussi pour la mise en place des
méthaniseurs enfin quand vous avez un
vrai besoin
le méthaniseur vous n'allez pas attendre
cinq ans aux six ans pour le voir juste
l'autorisation de le faire donc tout ça
c'est en train de on est en train de
simplifier justement le mais regardez et
la manière par exemple il ya un truc
formidable qui est prévu par l'europe
qui s'appelle l'autoconsommation
collective
ça permet à des gens de se mettre
ensemble et de produire de l'électricité
de cela vendre ou jusqu'à maintenant en
france est quasi impossible vous avez le
droit de faire ça si vous êtes 4 ou 5
mais au delà
niet ce qu'effectivement ça construit un
modèle énergétique est à l'opposé de
celui que nous avons aujourd'hui qui est
un modèle centralisé
c'est totalement décentralisé voilà donc
ça c'est des choses est à bloc
j'attends de voir s'ils vont de bardos
parce que des gens des nahdistes
notamment encourage les mois je suis
dans la ruralité encourage des petits
villages justement à se doter soit
d'éoliennes soit de ferme solaire pour
justement mettre en commun l'énergie et
pouvoir la revendre donc c'est quand
même remonter un tout petit peu au
niveau de l'état et du chef de l'état
allez-y vous voulez compléter mais je
voudrais vous faire commenter les
annonces aussi en fait y'a pas d'annoncé
mais quand même on va vous montrer
rapidement montré non mais c'est un
point essentiel la discussion qui qui
qui s'amorce entre monsieur le député
bruno myle yens et madame corinne lepage
qui était est ce que c'est les citoyens
le problème d'acceptation des citoyens
ou est ce que c'est la faille de la
volonté politique en gros le débat il
est là et l'argumentation du camp macro
nhien du gouvernement c'est à dire ah
mais on voudrait bien mais les citoyens
ne veulent pas c'est faux c'est faux
pour une grande part pas pour tous mais
pour une grande partie des choix et une
grande partie d une volonté politique
tout ce que j'ai cités très rapidement
les citoyens entendent dire dans sa
barbe installer des éoliennes vous allez
non mais d autres sujets il ya des
sujets qui sont absolument qui pose
problème kif qui ne seront pas contents
s'il ya le projet quand on revient aux
problèmes de l'environnement
les gens ils sont tout à fait d'accord
avec les enquêtes publiques ils sont
d'accord
je suis les enquêtes publiques c'est
avant de construire c'est ça oui mais
quand vous avez un détrôner
officiellement dénoncée bat pour faire
plaisir aux citoyens les membres du crew
regarder à paris jl gohelle a fait une
grosse politiques et les pas là quand
même payer ça sur son image il m'a
écouté on verra en mars et on verra en
marche et la division de l'opposition
qui profite parce que c'était courageux
tout est bon très bon c'était courage
apparemment elle est acceptée par
beaucoup des citoyens pour les voies sur
berges et la politique des vélos et je
crois qu'on verra en mars je veux pas
faire de prévisions allaient donc ça
c'est le premier mois donc la volonté
politique manque plus que dans beaucoup
de cas l'acceptation des citoyens mais
ne mesure pas de mesures y en a quand
même qui ont été annoncées évident mais
on va les regarder juste vous redonne la
parole
extension des aires protégées à 30 % du
territoire c'est la création de nouveaux
parcs naturels régionaux d'un grand plan
de transition énergétique pour les 2
millions 400 mille agents de l'état avec
des parkings à vélo avec des bornes
électriques je vous vois sourire évolué
sur et vention des inondations et
l'érosion des côtes et la création donc
enfin ce lancement plutôt de l'office
français de la biodiversité c'est nul
c'est ça pas du tout et d'en reporter on
a dit que par exemple la politique de
prévention de des débuts de protection
des habitations le long de la côte
par rapport à la montée des eaux est une
bonne chose donc vous voyez on n'a pas
une opposition systématique ont à peine
critique systématique faut en revanche
lorraine compte la protection désert des
déserts protéger il faut des personnes
il faut des gardes-forestiers il faut
des agents de la faiseuse de la bio
diversité pour que ces instances
donc si vous créez on n'est pas les
miens derrière et il faudrait les
réponses de minutes
mais comme j'avais trois phrases mal sur
l'avion par exemple quand madame ben 10
on va demander aux fonctionnaires de ne
pas prendre l'avion et de prendre le
train c'est très gentil mais en fait
c'est plutôt il a pu augmenter le prix
du kérosène empêcher l'extension des
aéroports privilégiez les trains de nuit
c'est le genre de chose qu'il faudrait
faire si on voulait vraiment lutter
contre le trafic dans des 2 millions 700
mille agents c'est quand même pas rien
qui donc les services publics qui
passent au vert on se dit quand même 2
millions 400 mille personnes d'abord
tombe à essayer d'accompagner la
transition écologique et ça c'est des
politiques du personnel moi je mène un
cabinet je vous assure qu'on prend
l'avion que quand on peut vraiment pas
faire autrement et autrement trempe on
prend le train en face est normal dans
toutes les entrevues clé c'est comme ça
que ça doit se passer enfin franchi
cette étape
enfin c'est pas la révolution sur les
pnrc les régions qui créent les pnr
sapins naturels régionaux maires
observations et deuxième observation et
monsieur le député vous le savez aussi
bien que moi un pnr ça n'empêche pas des
grosses cochonneries comme des belles
carrières alors l'ami lieu d'aborder
avec corinne lepage et avec mon nom me
l'avez vous dire président de la
république ya quand même des choses
qu'il faut il faut il faut quand même un
petit peu resté un petit peu à la
réalité si vous ne si vous n'assurez pas
des trucs derrière et se font pas moi je
trouve que ce qui est fait pour le pour
l'administration les annonces c'est pas
non plus le nirvana mais très bien pour
une fois que l'état s'applique à lui
même ce qu'il veut appliquer un jour
c'est pas là c'est là une des premières
fois qu'on voit ça
il ya quand même des choses qui ont été
faites pendant certaines lois comme la
loi d'orientation des mobilités qui
faillit qui favorisent la mobilité
durable
ça c'est quand même bien aussi moi je le
vois dans nos campagnes si demain on
arrive effectivement à avoir des flottes
autonome électrique pour rabattre les
gens vers les gares chacun prenne sa
bagnole qu'on développe le covoiturage
tout ça c'est des trucs qui sont
enclenchées alors évidemment l'état on
demande tout à l'état savait l'état ne
peut pas tout je ne sais pas moi qui
l'aï juste une phrase dans la loi sur
l'air votée en 1996 bagatelle de 24 ans
il y avait l'obligation pour les flottes
captives de l'état et des collectivités
locales d'avoir 10 % de voitures propres
vous croyez qu'ils ont été les 10 % de
votes nadal est d'accord connais pas je
serais d'accord donc ma part au pro chez
nous
on va pas reprocher aujourd'hui alors
qu'on entend parler de combat du siècle
c'est vrai que ce complet décalage on
l'entend est compris dans l'eau
nettement je veux pas taper sur les
gouvernements précédents mais
honnêtement on a entendu et quand il l'a
pas je sais très bien beaucoup de belles
déclarations beaucoup de beaux textes
riz ou ont été faites les applications
donc vos vêtements ou et elodie pas
l'hypothèse où vous défendez les petits
matins je voudrais vous êtes notre
chroniqueur vous êtes aussi
correspondant du quotidien suisse le
temps correspondant à paris
votre regard sur ce tournant vers que
prend la france que prend le président
de la république comment nos voisins
européens le regarde bon choix ou pas
bien j'entendais tout à l'heure une
formule pas de consensus sur les
solutions mais c'est quand même un peu
ce qui se passe en europe
parce que quand l'europe regarde la
france regarde emmanuel macron en haut
du mont blanc prononcer ces différentes
mesures et bien l'europe elle regarde
plutôt en bas et qu'est ce qu'on voit en
bas du mont blanc pas très très loin la
centrale nucléaire du bugey et c'est
effectivement du nucléaire qu'il faut
parler parce que je vais vous citer une
date on est en novembre 2010 est
emmanuel macron vient d'être élu il
réunit à paris le one planet summit
il y à une brochette de chefs d'état de
gouvernement il y à arnold
schwarzenegger on va le voir en photo à
vis du président aulas et opérationnels
philly à une annonce 1500 milliards de
dollars pour le climat n'est angela
merkel n'est pas du tout contente parce
qu'elle voit 15 milliards pour
l'industrie nucléaire
et là il pique une colère parce que vous
savez que les allemands le nucléaire ils
ont dit nein en 2011 suite au séisme
japonais et à l'accident de fond j'ai eu
ma maison et donc il y a là un différend
majeur il y a un différend qui va on va
voir on va pouvoir le tester manel macro
tout bientôt parce que que va-t-il se
passer le 22 février la semaine
prochaine le premier réacteur de la
centrale de fessenheim doit fermer la
centrale de fessenheim c'est la plus
vieille centrale française exploité
depuis 1978 mais alors quels romans
feuilletons et que la fermeture de
fessenheim
on va écouter manuel macron 2018 il
expliquait que lui il était déterminé il
allait la faire mais je n'ai pas été élu
pour ma part sur un pro
de sortie du nucléaire mais sur une
réduction à 50% de la part du nucléaire
dans notre mix électrique
yjc de la verrai après expertise
pragmatique que ce chiffre brandi comme
un totem politique était dans les faits
inatteignable nous avons donc décidé de
maintenir ce cap des 50% mais en
repoussant l'échéance à 2035
alors alors qu'est-ce que fessenheim
enfermé donc rendez vous la semaine
prochaine
c'est edf qui a un projet puisque ça
doit devenir un technocentre de
déconstruction des centrales là on peut
se poser la question mais il y a encore
un autre problème rien c'est que cette
filière nucléaire
et bien elle a exporté en europe et il y
a deux réacteurs dont vraiment les
européens ne veulent plus entendre
parler madame lepage vous avez
suffisamment siéger pour le savoir c'est
celui en finlande de haut qui alors je
vais me les le talkie loto et celui de
inc l'époque au royaume uni
alors là les factures ont littéralement
explosé se permet vous inquiétez pas
parce que jusqu'au flamanville c'est pas
fini et c'est pas loin et greenpeace
était donc parti à l'assaut de ces deux
réacteurs notamment en finlande bref sur
le côté climat et à cause du nucléaire
on voit qu emmanuel macron à quelques
casseroles en fission et quand on sait
qu'en allemagne il y aura peut-être
demain une coalition entre les chrétiens
démocrates et les verts
ça promet de bardet sévèrement il faut
dire que le président français il a un
argument il vend ses réacteurs prn et
xinhua la ddt respectivement premier et
troisième pollueur mondial la france a
regardé comme à l'avant garde de les
convier à cause du nucléaire
moi je veux bien tout un les allemands
arrêter le nucléaire moi aussi je
voudrais bien mais arrêtez de nous taire
et de remplacer le nucléaire par quoi et
charbon le charbon est en fait sauf que
depuis 2010 9 vous savez comme moi qu'il
ya plus de production verte que de
charbon en wheeling mais jusqu'à
maintenant la france produisait moins de
carbone et de gaz à effet de serre six
fois moins que les allemands grâce au
nucléaire
alors ok on peut on peut être contre le
nucléaire ça je suis d'ailleurs c'est la
raison pour laquelle c'est la principale
raison pour laquelle on est très en
retard sur les énergies renouvelables
assure alors je voudrais qu'on tape sur
le truc mais tellement retard sur des
énergies renouvelables qu'on a demandé
aux citoyens je reviens à vous
bien blanches et de trouver les
solutions pour réduire si j'ai bonne
mémoire de 40% les émissions d'ici à
2030 dont d'une logique de justice
sociale le haut conseil pour le climat
nous dit déjà qu'on est en retard on va
pas assez vite il vous y arrivez
franchement les citoyens on va réussir à
réduire de 40% avec une convention il
s'agit pas de faire peser l'entièreté de
la responsabilité de la politique
climatique de l'état français sur ces
150 lotis ça n'est pas le sujet le sujet
c'est comment on peut avoir des mesures
qui ont un impact réel qui sont acceptés
socialement et aux citoyens quand on va
sur le site
oui très bien que leur objectif c'est
d'arriver à faire des propositions pour
réduire s'inscrivent dans cette
trajectoire ce sont les engagements de
la france donc effectuons mais pourquoi
il n'y arrivera ce que j'entends et
physiquement ça fait longtemps que on a
des solutions
un pardon mais j'ai pas le sentiment
qu'elles aient toutes été mises en
oeuvre et on peut estimer que c'est par
manque de courage on peut aussi estimer
que c'est pas parce que la population ne
voulait pas pour une partie d'entre
elles ou que les mesures
d'accompagnement n'était pas suffisante
parce que c'est ça aussi il a d'ailleurs
les 150 dans leurs délibérations ils
disent bon ben ça ok comment est ce
qu'on la compagne pour que le dernier
décile par exemple des revenus ne soient
pas les plus intègres impactés
comment est-ce qu'on accompagne aussi au
niveau de l'emploi parce que ils ont pu
entendre un certain nombre d'acteurs est
effectivement mais l'impact sur l'emploi
peut être il regarde le bilan des
citoyens dont vous suivez les débats
sont de vision homogène ou parce qu'ils
représentent des réalités sociales et
territoriales différentes ben y en a qui
pensent qu ils sont diverses
ils sont diverses et c'est la volonté
que nous avons eues dans ce tirage au
sort c'est qu'il soit diverses donc ils
sont comme la population française ici
on bienveillant mais d'être et défiant
très peur d'être instrumentalisés ils
ont envie de servir ils sont fiers de
leur travail je peux vous dire que il on
a beaucoup travaillé sur cette dernière
session qui était le week end dernier 1
et c'est vrai que pour la première
oeuvre là ils se sont mis d'accord sur
les textes ils se sont confrontés entre
eux et ça c'est très intéressant d'avoir
des gens qui est aussi un moment se
confrontent entre eux dans une salle de
manière respectacle respectable sans
être dans les faits deux tribunes
moi je crois que c'est aussi un chemin
pour trouver des solutions parce que
on peut continuer cet appel fut encore
pendant trente ans mais globalement le
la mer de glace
elle existera plus c'est sûr on va
terminer ce débat en changeant un tout
petit peu d'échelle tout à l'heure
stéphane nous le disait au fond ainsi
les autres ne font rien les états unis
la chine l'europe et bien notre action
sera sera ridicule
emmanuel macron alors peut-être vous le
trouvez bouffon sur la scène nationale
mais est-ce qu'il n'est pas un de ceux
qui poussent le plus haut niveau
européen sur le pré carbone sur le fait
de faire payer les pollueurs aux
frontières de l'europe sur ce fameux
green new deal
non non et par exemple un cas très
concret c'est la france n'a pas rendu sa
feuille de route pour le climat à
l'union européenne alors qu'elle aurait
dû le faire déjà depuis quelques mois
donc monsieur macron s'est déplacé
énormément en europe de ce point de vue
là il a raison l'europe est absolument
être un espace géopolitique dans lequel
on doit s'inscrire mais il ne bouge pas
vraiment sur les questions climatiques
qui devrait d'accord corinne lepage
vêtements et je lui dire il faut pas
avoir une vue on n'est pas un meilleur
ambassadeur de la cause au niveau
européen
non je pense qu'il ya d'autres pays par
exemple malgré leur départ les anglais
font énormément de choses dans ce
domaine c'est épique comme l'autriche ou
les pays du nord de l'europe qui à mon
sens en font beaucoup plus que nous et
ce que je voulais dire faut pas avoir
une vision uniforme des états unis us et
les états unis sont quand même baissé de
près de 3 % leurs émissions de gaz à
effet de serre l'année dernière alors
trump fait tout ce qui peut dans l'autre
sens mais il ya beaucoup d'américains et
d'état américain qui sont tout à fait
conscients de leurs responsabilités
le mot de la fin revenant aux 1000 yens
la france est très attendue mais les
européens également et à entendre les
spécialistes de l'écologie est bien le
compte n'y est pas à nouveau on sait
bien que le compte n'y est pas forcément
on le sait ça on voit pas le monde sait
gérer mieux dire le chiffres le prouvent
le green new deal robinson moindre lueur
d'espoir que l'europe a envie de se
mettre en marche
enfin sur ce sur ce sujet avec les
moyens financiers ce qu'on avait pas
jusqu'à maintenant
donc ça c'est au moins une bonne
nouvelle et puis je dis je voulais vous
dire aussi une petite chose c'est que
chacun sur nos territoires on peut agir
je ne ferme de l'auto pub j'ai créé une
fondation qui s'appelle au coeur des
territoires et dont la principale
mission c'est d'insérer de l'économie
verte sur le territoire pour que les
gens puissent à nouveau
travailler et vivre à côté de chez eux
sur ce message locales pour l'écologie
merci à tous vous restez avec nous
corinne lepage voudrait qu'on évoque à
présent votre combat pour lubrizol je le
disais vous avez attaqué l'entreprise
américaine après l'incendié de
l'entrepôt de roue on va en parler mais
d'abord les députés veulent aller plus
loin que le gouvernement contre les
accidents industriels il remettait un
rapport hier on va écouter damien adam
députée de la circonscription de seine
maritime à rouen et rapporteur de cette
mission parlementaire était au micro de
vincent crâne l1 il ya vraiment une
notion important sur la lutte contre les
risques industriels s assurer que les
services de l'état soit vraiment le plus
mobilisé possible pour s'assurer que
l'ensemble des parties prenantes
industriels partenaires les industriels
sites seveso et site juste industriel
mais sans avoir le statut de seveso soit
bien contrôler ils ont la bonne
nomenclature et qu'après il ya une
situation qu'a chaque accident puisse
vraiment apprendre d'eux des erreurs qui
ont pu être faits par les industriels à
travers le bureau d'enquêté accident qui
va permettre à l'ensemble de l'industrie
de s'améliorer à chaque fois voilà on va
augmenter les contrôles sur l'ensemble
des sites et pas uniquement les seveso
qui était vraiment dans l'oeil du
cyclone après l'accident
c'est une bonne nouvelle mais il n'en
sait très bien mais il faut pas faire du
yaka fokon c'est à dire que augmenter
les contrôles c'est bien mais pour qui
une augmentation des contrôles comme
dirait la pallice il faut une
augmentation des contrôleurs or je n'ai
pas vu du tout l'état s'est engagé à
augmenter les contrôles de 50 % oui mais
comment s'il augmente pas le nombre de
fonctionnaires ça veut dire que les
tâches par exemple je l' ai bien vu le
papier qui a été fait ça veut dire que
les pprt les plans ou la panique les
plans de protection contrôle des risques
technologiques ce qui est très important
pour tous les voisins
bah on va en faire moins ou plus
longuement ou autrement parce que les
gens ne peuvent pas si vous ne mentez
pas le nombre des contrôleurs vous n'y
arrivez pas deuxièmement bien sûr c'est
bien d'augmenter les contrôles mais je
rappelle quand même que lubrizol
ils ont eu 19 ou 20 contrôle de la dréal
pour faire quoi s'il vous plaît quand on
apprend par exemple ça date de la
semaine dernière que l'assureur de
lubrizol les ont les ont mis en garde
depuis plusieurs années et le plus
récemment c'était quelques jours avant
l'incendié sur le fait que leurs
systèmes d'incendié n'était pas
opérationnel
et ils ont décrit par le menu ce qui
s'est effectivement passé
la dre elle l a fait quoi la badr assez
basses et l'inspection dé valenciennes
inspection des installations classées
les quinquas roller dont vous parliez de
deux choses l'une ou bien ils le
savaient et à ce moment pourquoi n'ont
ils rien fait oublier ne le savais pas
et recommence sont déroulées les
contrôles voilà donc si vous voulez
c'est très bien le principe mais il faut
aussi que les contrôleurs puissent aller
au bout de leurs contrôles puissent
mettre des mises en demeures aux
industriels quand les choses ne vont pas
or je ne suis pas certaine que sur
lubrizol
en effet toutes les mises en demeure
qu'il fallait au moment où il fallait
les faire alors justement pas de mise en
demeure et pourtant l'ouverture du site
oui alors vous avez échoué dans sa déjà
gars seul humain il faut expliquer un
vous défendiez un collectif citoyen
association rouen respirons est une qui
est une association reconnue avec le
statut d'association de victimes qui
demandait la suspension du redémarrage
de cette installation précisément parce
qu'on sait toujours pas les causes de
l'accident
et parce que il bien il ya énormément
d'incertitudes tribunal administratif ne
nous a pas donné raison je le regrette
mais il ya quelque chose qui m'a
beaucoup interpellé dans cette histoire
là c'est la communication des documents
et je me tourne vers vous monsieur le
député parce que je pense qu'un problème
de fond aujourd'hui on ne donne plus les
informations ni aux riverains ni même au
maire ni aux services de pompiers n'y a
personne au motif qu' il faut pas donné
d'éléments sur le terrorisme on est tous
d'accord là dessus je parle train de
vous dire qu'il faut faciliter la vie
des terroristes en attendant en
attendant personne ne sait plus rien sur
les études de danger sur les rapports de
l'administration sur les procès verbaux
etc
dans ce pinceau y avait des choses
classés défense parce qu'elle n'est pas
placé défense classe est classé par loin
oui secret mais secret ya pas de raison
qu'on enlève secret parce que dangereux
créer un
friel c'est à ce moment là vous n'aurez
jamais de culture du rhône ans mais je
souhaitais pour répondre des patients
c'est un secret défense ce qui venait
aux sorties au moment de l'accident mais
bien un début à l'elysée lors d'un
procès qui s'est tenu il ya des
documents qui ne nous ont pas été
communiqués qui ont été données au
tribunal et pas au parti je considère
que ça pose réellement un problème qu'on
me dise on veut pas savoir où sont les
caméras de surveillance je m'en fous des
caméras de surveillance est pas mon
problème
par contre qu'on ne puisse pas savoir ce
qu'a dit le contrôleur quand il est venu
sur place l'inspecteur quand il est venu
sur place d'un document adore ce
mécréant forme ce que vous répondez oui
je vais pas rentrer dans le détail du
rapport qui a été produit par mes
collègues
adam et bouillon parce que d'abord le
rapport à je trouve qu'il est très bien
fait et il amène des solutions notamment
sur les sujets que vous avez évoquées
moi je voulais rebondir un petit peu sur
les pprt aussi parce que je ne la
tension protection voilà contre les
risques tecnoma cas moi je voudrais
aussi qu'on soit conscient là il faut
une vraie conscience collective parce
qu'il n'ya pas que l'état qui est fautif
dans ces fameux pprt souvent les élus
locaux mettent la pression pour ne pas
perdre de foncier et de pour pouvoir
installer donc des logements des
bâtiments autour de ces de ses sites
industriels dangereux plus de seveso
plus de sites de ce type dans cette
approche est désormais si on fait
vraiment des seveso il faut qu'on ait
des pprt qui soit respectée et qui ait
pas de pression des locaux fohrer voilà
il ya ça aussi par rapport à la
protection la politique manière en fait
à ma manière
jean fernandez je lai le dossier de
lubrizol je m'en occupe
et beaucoup beaucoup d'autres c'est à ma
manière à moi de d'essayer d'être
efficace vous savez quand vous arrivez à
certains moments de votre vie vous vous
dites qu'il n'ya plus tendres tant que
ça devant pour être efficace et essayer
de faire passer
l'expérience qui est la vôtre j'ai
choisi aujourd'hui de le faire plus par
le droit que par la politique ce qui ne
m'empêche pas d'avoir la parole libre
peut-être plus qu'avant et c'est aussi
une manière de faire de la politique est
vraiment continuer à entendre votre
liberté de parole parce qu'on va parler
d'un sujet éminemment écologique aussi
et 80 km/heure merci à tous à l'heure
depuis le début d'année vous le savez
les présidents des conseils
départementaux peuvent revenir aux 90
km/heure à certaines conditions alors
est ce si facile
et combien de départements l'ont fait
hélène bonduelle nous dresse le bilan de
ce retour autorisé regarder exit les 80
voici revenu les 90 km heure en tout cas
dans certains départements
le cantal par exemple est repassée il ya
quelques jours à la vitesse supérieure
sur tout son réseau routier
départemental s'était porté en plus
attendus dans un département comme le
cantal
nous circulons très majoritairement et
fonctionnement sur ce fameux réseau
secondaire donc plus que tout temps que
nous avions mesuré les inconvénients de
l'abaissement de la vitesse à 80
km/heure nous avions retrouvé dans ce
département c'est un déplacement des
temps de trajet des années 80 et ceci
après avoir conduit des investis pour
gagner et en sécurité
coût de l'opération des allers retours
des panneaux 60000 euros
d'autres au contraire ne veulent pas
revenir en arrière
convaincu par l'expérimentation de la
baisse de la vitesse
elle va dans le sens ceux de plus de
protection elle va dans le sens aussi
des économies d'énergie et puis aussi
même pour les usagers des économies
financières sur nos routes
départementales en un semestre le nombre
de tués était divisé quasiment par deux
jamais le premier ministre n'aurait dû
revenir sur cette mesure de 80 km
d'autant qu' edouard philippe est
longtemps resté inflexible sur les 80
kilomètres heure l'objectif savais pas
dans le meilleur des mondes
l'objectif faire en sorte qu'ils aient
mois mort
et moins de blessés graves pourtant en
plein mois de juillet 2018 il déclenche
la colère des automobilistes et bientôt
celle des gilet jaune 75% des radars
sont même détruit et lors du grand débat
le président de la république est obligé
de temporiser
il faut ensemble qu'on trouve sur ce
sujet aussi par le débat une manière
plus intelligente de le mettre en oeuvre
on pourrait trouver quelque chose de
plus pragmatiques qu'ils soient mieux
accepter qu'ils aient le même résultat
alors après avoir salué la baisse de la
mortalité sur les routes
grâce à la mesure le gouvernement finit
par céder
la loi d'orientation des mobilités
prévoit une dérogation mais c'est aux
élus locaux de prendre la décision
les élus avec une suspicion de possibles
responsabilités à ce jour une trentaine
de départements ont choisi de revenir à
90 km/heure sur leurs routes étroites
invités nous ont rejoints sur ce plateau
chantal perrichon bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous est la présidente de la
ligue contre la violence routière
philippe vigier merci d'être là vous
êtes député liberté et territoires
d'eure-et-loir coprésident du groupe
liberté et territoires enfin j'accueille
il fera bon soit il kara pardonnez moi
vous êtes le porte parole de
l'automobile club alors qu'il vise y est
je voudrais vous demander déjà si votre
département a choisi de rester aux 80 km
heure ou pas pour l'instant il est
encore à 80 km/heure le président du
département annoncé lors de ses voeux
d'ailleurs qu'il souhaitait que l'on
puisse relever la vitesse sur certains
axes en fonction de différentes
caractéristiques nouvelles qui sont
imposées aux départements qui souhaitent
faire cette démarche car ça se fait pas
de façon automatique et que dans les
fameux circulaire tels que j'ai pu être
rédigé
et on doit obéir à sa tombe de deux
critères assez strictes d'ailleurs vous
cette liberté de revenir aux 97 vous
tient à coeur
moi elle me tient à coeur en plus dans
un département des grandes d'une droite
qui dure 10 15 km et c'est la beauce
dont c'est extrêmement plat
j'ai pu comprendre qu'à certains
endroits et justement des
infrastructures qui ne permettent pas de
rouler à la vitesse de 90 mais les
chiffres de la mortalité sur les routes
sur la route nationale 10 où je me
bagarre pour cette route où j'ai même vu
venir il y avait deux bornes ya un an et
demi où j'attends toujours la
notification de la notification précise
de tous les aménagements de sécurité
qu'on va faire oui il ya longtemps que
je mène ce combat puisqu'il ya dix ans
lorsque dominique bussereau était
ministre des transports j'avais obtenu
une enveloppe financière pour faire une
étude de sécurité routière entre
chartres et tour et nous venons
d'inaugurer la première réalisation il
ya un mois et demi
20 morts après voilà et malheureusement
lorsqu'on a été maire qu'il était
pendant longtemps et que l'on a dû aller
au bord des accidents on comprend mieux
les choses sur telle opération cet
argument qui consiste à fond a redonné
de la liberté de la flexibilité sur les
routes secondaires
après ce qui s'est dit au moment de la
crise des dg des jaunes est ce que vous
y êtes totalement insensible je suis pas
insensible à tout ce qui est dit ça peut
quelquefois m'agacer pourquoi parce
qu'on parle de la vie des gens et si on
prend le département de monsieur il ya
de quoi se préoccuper quand même il doit
savoir que par million de tués par
million d'habitants tués et 1 mètre
parcouru km vous êtes 71e sur 96 vous
n'êtes vraiment pas un bon départ pour
danser lorsque l'eau et l'eau oui mais
la route nationale normalement à moins
que les choses aient changé depuis
quelques jours elle revient à l'état
donc elle doit rester à 80 donc nous ne
parlons des départementales sur les
biens sont les accidents le mois d'avril
j'ai toutes les statistiques oui bien
sûr une fois de plus j'ai regardé ça de
façon extrêmement précise simplement
pour venir à votre rencontre ce soir
n'en viennent à leur tour d'horizon et
aux 90 sont uniquement pour les belles
bacchantes fantastique ordre excellent
nous sommes d'accord la nationale 10
reste à 80 puisque ce n'est pas de votre
héros gatti la gloire et à 80 mais si on
regarde vous avez en fait quatorze voix
qui sont concernés
on retrouve 54 % des tués sur quatorze
fois uniquement
et lorsque je vous entends dire je nous
avons des belles routes droites
c'est ce que nous entendons en
permanence et c'est sur ces routes que
l'on va libérer l'animal pourquoi parce
que il y à du trafic bien évidemment
c'est pour ça qu'il y a des belles
infrastructures etc le trafic qui fait
le danger
prenons un exemple simple que tout le
monde peut comprendre tout le monde sait
que les autoroutes sont à peu près
équivalente bien et bien des autoroutes
où le risque est plus grand que sur
d'autres pourquoi parce qu'il ya plus de
trafic c'est plus dangereux si vous êtes
entre lyon et marseille que sur des
autoroutes - circuler ce qui fait le
danger c'est l'autre alors revenons aux
chiffres de la mortalité routière qui
sont au plus bas historique 336 vies
épargnées selon l'observatoire de la
sécurité routière est ce qu on sait la
part imputable à cette règle des 80
et puis un précisément le séré makita
centre d'études et de recherche a fait
une étude comparative sur la moyenne
concernant le 80 km heure par rapport
aux cinq dernières années
donc on sait ce qu'il en est c'est
beaucoup moins que ce qu'on n'est pas
qu'on espérait nous le savons mais quand
même rappeler qu'il y a eu des radars
détruit et il y a eu en plus une
certaine obstination de la délégation à
la sécurité routière qui les remplacent
est c'est-à-dire qui crée des jouets
pour les casseurs c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous n'avons cessé de demander
qu'il y ait des contrôles dans les
voitures banalisées
si la vitesse n'est pas en contrôle et
vous savez ce qu'on appelle à peu près
25 à 30% de légitimiste à dire les
conducteurs 10 ans borné à 80 je suis à
80 vous y en avait qui hésitent encore
un petit peu plus à l'est les opposants
ceux qui sont contre alors maintenant on
voit que d'ailleurs les opposants 80 ils
ont beaucoup baissé
il était très important alors justement
cas sur l'essence aux départements
français il car à 101 départements
français 22 départements sont revenus
aux 90 km heure 22 vous dites c'est déjà
ça tant mieux
ou finalement c'est pas alors il faut
dire une chose
ils vont revenir ils sont pas encore un
rêve qu'ils ont fait la démarche mission
aucune route qui va compliquer alors il
se dit que nous les démarches c'est
important de le dire parce qu'un certain
neil de conditions à remplir
vous savez nous on était ça fait des
années que ce 80 km heure
reposez on sait pas qu'on était content
on est pour une juste vitesse dire que
si à 90 c'est bien parce que la route
est en bon état il n'y a pas de souci
mais on n'était pas même pas pour 80
pour soixante dix parce que l'on va
mettre 50 30 70 80 90 était trop dont
condé on disait descendez la vitesse à
70 on peut vous aider à faire l'audit
des routes on a les systèmes nous dans
les automobile clubs européens et puis
quand les travaux seront faits vous la
remettra à 90 il faut qu'elle soit
acceptée une mesure pour qu'elle soit
efficace
elle n'est pas acceptée les pas efficace
puis vous savez dans tous les débats que
j'ai fait sur 6 80 km ans et j'en ai
fait quelques centaines imagine la
vitesse moyenne avant de passer à 90 à
80 était de 81 2 km ans pour moi qu'il
dit 1,82 tout ça pour 2 km heure donc
c'est inutile et je vais vous dire qu'on
soit 80 90 un jeune qui sort de boîte
quatre obus qui a pris de la drogue qui
regarde son téléphone 80 90 son problème
est et c'est là qu'est le vrai problème
alors corinne lepage n'a pas encore
parler j'aimerais avoir son regard et
vous répondrais oui c'est promis c'est
vrai que la question de la sécurité
routière est quand même une question
essentielle on dit est un des pays
d'europe où les taux étaient les plus
catastrophiques c'est un des combats de
jacques chirac celui grand ce sujet là
il voulait absolument le faire baisser
et il y est arrivé
ensuite je crois que là aussi
l'uniformité c'est pas toujours une très
bonne règle je veux dire par là qu'il ya
des routes où on est à 80 moi je me dis
on prête à 50 là c'est franchement
dangereux le sud c'est franchement
dangereux enfin aussi à des routes où on
est avec les copains et on pourrait
aller un peu plus loin je pense que
chacun commence à lui je suis pas sûr
que ce soit toujours dangereux alors si
on ne peut pas effectivement se mettre
d'accord sur les tracés sur les trajets
etc
restons à 80 mais moi j'aimerais plus de
souplesse qui permettent aussi de
baisser beaucoup plus que 80 à l'heure
parce que je trouve qu'il ya des
endroits où c'est trop dangereux ce que
chantal l'éruption va vous répondre
attendez pardonnez-moi mais consommer
les vrais débats le père ici parce que
je n'ai pas encore est seul
alors nous avons entendu des débats à
peu près identique
lorsqu'on est passé de 60 à 50 en ville
il y avait des villes
vous pouvez rester à 60 ou le bon sens
laisser subodorer que et on est toujours
avec des gens qui imaginent qu'ils
pensent qu'il subodore qui n'ont on
arrête avec ça il ya dans ce pays des
épidémiologistes
il ya des scientifiques qui nous
expliquer qui nous sommes et qui nous
prouve ce qu'il en est de la vitesse la
vitesse il ne faut jamais oublier que
c'est l'élément déclenchant de
l'accident et que évidemment c'est un
élément qui va aggraver les blessures
c'est donc important quand j'entends
dire on peut passer à 50 ou 70 mais
pourquoi diable les départements qui
sont dans la réserve actuelle quand on
n'a pas la déferlante que l'on attendait
et vient de qui n'ont pas encore
effectivement il y en a qui disent on
observe ce que rim lyonnaise s'est pas
vraiment de la sécurité des bateaux de
trop pour vous hein
il faut quand même prendre ses
responsabilités et non pas au doigt levé
ni comme ça en pensant et en imaginant
que nous regardons les études
d'accidentalité du pro mais madame
perrichon il ya une décision de matignon
quéré de choisir la souplesse la soute
est elle existe depuis le début de
l'année moi ce que je voudrais savoir si
c'est au fond un piège du gouvernement
que d'avoir rendu tellement compliqué
l'europe le retour aux 90 avec beaucoup
de conditions c'est ce que dit par
exemple jean rené lecerf le président du
département du nord qui dénoncera
foutage de gueule et qui dit il faudrait
au fond construire des routes dans les
nuages pourra réussir à remplir toutes
les conditions il faut qu'il y ait 100
riverains sans arrêt de bus sans engin
agricole qu'elle fasse au moins 10 km et
qu'elles soient équipées de radars dits
sans piste cyclable qui les travers et
vous avez oublié les accotements la
largeur des causes accotements parce que
lorsqu'il ya salutaire de roues drôle
beaucoup d'anglais que les zones rurales
par exemple que vous venez de nouveau
vous interroge la série ce qu'on appelle
le programme voiture c'est pas le
gouvernement qui a claqué du doigt en
disant je veux imposer ça pour piéger
il a simplement appliqué un programme
qui correspond à l'infrastructure oms
n'a où il ya une aberration c'est quand
il ya eu le vote à l'assemblée nationale
d'un amendement qui était aberrant il
fallait pas que l'état se départisse de
son rôle régalien pour les vitesses
maximales
est-ce qu'on va décider par exemple pour
les vaccinations vous avez une formation
dix ans de pharmaciens je pense
est-ce que vous allez décider dans votre
département un jour parce que vous avez
fait des études que cette vaccination ne
vous agrée plus non il y a des des
départements six à avoir
nous on peut passer
vous êtes 3 je suis un petit peu il
avait d'abord on a pris la chance je
vais vous dire une chose bien à dijon
je vais vous dire une chose par contre
vous pas du tout on nous avait pas le
monopole du combat pour la lutte contre
l'insécurité routière
j'espère madame je voulais vous dire que
dans ma commune on a limité le centre
ville à 30 km heure que c'est votre
serviteur qui a fait changer sur la
saône à 10 vous vérifierez tous les
villages entre chartres et vandomme en
loir et cher sont tous à 50
avant c'était 70 donc je veux plus
entendre ce sketch selon lequel nous
nous sommes deux délinquants parce qu'on
veut faire cela
deuxième chose j'ai vu des mots du me
semble-t-il sont bien apparues après
appropriée c'est le fait la vitesse
juste je m'explique il y a des routes
sur lesquelles à 80 km/heure on est en
danger
or on ne dit pas mot on ne dit rien
ensuite la j'aimerais vous dire pourquoi
vous êtes un danger pour par la vitesse
est trop élevé parce que ces 11 88 81 84
oui oui la vitesse à certains endroits
sur des routes départementales et je
connais très bien et dans les accidents
vous le savez tout aussi bien que moi et
mieux que moi c'est dans les habitudes
domicile travail
c'est lorsque le matin ou le soir
dernier mot pardonnez-moi la vitesse oui
mais pas que la vitesse 1 moi j'attends
j'attends deux choses
les contrôles d'alcoolémie et de
stupéfiants et je le fais dans mon
métier de biologistes et je peux vous
dire que là vous avez des marges de
manoeuvre considérable
sajoo l'attend on ne le fait pas et la
deuxième chose nous parler des camions
de seconde qui continue de vous dépasser
à 90 km/heure ou à 91 km heure et qui
sont des véritables dangers publics et
là on ne fait rien et donc quelque part
il fallait faire une annonce politique
de m à 80km un bon dieu moi je suis pour
principe du
suivent hilarité qu'on fasse confiance
aux élus locaux qui ne sont pas tous
délinquants elle et mes frères à qui n'a
pas encore parlé bolloré là bas parce
qu'on est on n'est pas toi quand tu n'es
pas content
la sécurité routière si je puis me
permettre
l'automobile club existe depuis 120 ans
on a été les premiers à créer les
panneaux on a été les premiers à créer
les permis de conduire
donc la sécurité routière on connaît
bien et on travaille tous les jours pour
ça oui mais on a l'impression à vous
entendre
au fond cette souplesse accordée aux
présentes département elle ne satisfait
personne c'est trop compliqué à mettre
en oeuvre et c'est trop dangereux et a
créé les conditions pour que ce soit
tellement difficile derrière le problème
de ces 80 kilomètres heure qui est un
débat passionné passionnel s'il vous
plaît c'est qu'ils masquent ce que
disait exactement monsieur tous les
autres toutes les autres actions
vraiment efficace pour la sécurité
routière la vitesse c'est 6 et je vais
vous dire ça va faire bondir mais ce
n'est pas le problème
le problème c'est l'inattention ce sont
les dix tracteurs c'est le téléphone
c'est l'alcool c'est la droite la drogue
et c'est la non formation et non
prévention de tous les conducteurs
français jeunes et moins jeunes
elle reste me reste une minute vous
allez je vous avez noté tous les
arguments vous avez besoin d éviter la
vitesse on ne tente pas n'est pas le
facteur
je vais vous seul simplement vous citez
quelque chose qui va rendre les choses
claires jeu qu'on a parlé de jacques
chirac tout à l'heure on a parlé des
radars eh bien lorsque les radars ont
permis de contrôler la vitesse la
vitesse moyenne d'antan parle elle a
baissé et nous avons retrouvé une deluxe
est là et nous avons retrouvé une
modélisation que tout le monde connaît
1% de vitesse moyenne en moins 4 pour
cent tués en moins alors s'envoler on
débat trop longtemps non non rien ne
sont pas concluants mais si vous
regardez les courbes de l'époque
vous allez voir que tous les facteurs
vous avez parlé de l'alcool ils ont
baissé de la même façon et tous les
usagers ont été vains
je crois moi je trouve jeunesse que les
constructeurs automobiles sont oubliés
dans la sécurité routière parce qu'ils
font beaucoup sur la sécurité passive et
voilà pour l'exemple et cher je voulais
qu'on dise un mot sur la dimension
écologique de la réduction de la vitesse
avant jc oui bien sûr attendait s'il
vous plaît coûté 1 ce quine du mal et
écologique parce qu il est tout à fait
exact que moi vous roulez vite et moins
vous consommez d'énergie c'est une
évidence
et j'ajoute que dans beaucoup de pays
voisins les vitesses autorisées sont
moindres que celles que nous avons chez
nous quand même
eh bien merci beaucoup débat passionnel
sur les limitations de vitesse 1 on s'en
doutait merci à vous c'est la fin de
cette émission merci à vous tous d'avoir
suivi bonsoir et à demain
[Musique]